you I'd like to thank the organizers for
inviting me here and I'd also like to
thank the Simon's Institute for making
my trip here possible it's great to be
here in to be giving this talk so this
talk is about polynomials and I have not
seen much of polynomials in this
workshop so far it's because it's not
exactly counting representing
polynomials in this way but of course
it's related and which is why I'm
talking about it here so this is joint
work with Nathan sourabh the term a
numerator polynomial is there is just
something that I made up and let me
start off by explaining what i mean by
this so let me start with an example
which is very well known to all of us
Hamilton cycles typically the typical
problem would be that there's an input
graph the object of interest is Hamilton
cycles if you ask whether the graph has
such a cycle will this is an np-complete
question if you ask how many Hamilton
cycles there are then this is a Sharpie
complete question and now one could also
ask for an explicit description of all
the Hamilton cycles in the graph so that
they could be just too many cycles so of
course an explicit description will have
to put them together in some form and
what we would ask for is an enumeration
of them in some symbolic way so in
particular if I have a new variable for
every edge I can construct a monomial
for every Hamilton cycle which just
multiplies the variables belonging to
that Hamilton cycle pick any cycle look
at the edges on that cycle look at the
variables appearing on those edges and
multiply them that's one monomial add up
all these monomials so we get a
polynomial and this polynomial it has
all the information that one could
possibly think about about the Hamilton
problem so therefore clearly we would
expect this polynomial to be very hard
to compute so just in case this notation
is a bit unfamiliar as an example of
listed out a few Hamilton cycles and the
corresponding monomials that they
generate so the point is that this as a
polynomial this must be a very hard
polynomial but then what is the
computational model we are talking about
when we say that the polynomial is hard
so for this let me quickly flash this
slide which I use all the time to
describe circuit so we are going to talk
about arithmetic circuits these are
directed acyclic graphs this graph is
directed all ologies go up and at
leaves we feed in either field constants
or variables which are of course
polynomials of the most simple type and
at intermediate gates we are processing
these polynomials either adding them
together or multiplying them together
and producing more and more polynomials
and finally there is one designated
output node whatever polynomial it
computes is computed by this circuit so
well such a circuit would compute one
polynomial we would be interested
typically in families of polymers
growing with n so we will talk about a
circuit family computing a polynomial
family and we are only interested in
polynomial families which are reasonable
reasonable in the sense that the NX
polynomial in the family has not too
many variables the number of variables
is polynomial in n it does not have too
high degree the degree is also
polynomial in N and it's easy to see
that the Hamilton cycles family
certainly satisfies this at the end the
NF polynomial has degree n and it has
only n square variables one for every
edge in the graph so we will only be
looking at such polynomial families
these are what we call p families of
polynomials and now one could ask how
big is the circuit that computes this
polynomial so there the obvious notion
is polynomial size computable if there
is a family of circuits of polynomial
size which computes this polynomial
family then that's great and that's what
a valiant called P computability when he
first defined this class and he also had
this notion of P define ability so P
compatibility is like the algebraic and
a log of P and P desirability is the
algebraic analog of NP so here's a very
formal description of it but even if you
don't want to see the formal definition
it's fine the these are just algebraic
analogs of P and NP and of course we're
in didn't call it that but now we call
them VP and B&B valence and a log of P
and railings analog of NP me so it's
it's clear that the Hamilton cycle
polynomial is in v NP it's very easy to
see this and in fact it is hard for v NP
so it's one of the hardest polynomial is
out there that's also not a surprise but
at this point maybe I should also say
that in this model I have not even
described how one would say that
something is hard so I need to specify
what is the kind of reduction that we're
going to use and we are going to
projection so projections is something
that we have seen before I have the
slide so let me go through it again
anyway here is an example polynomial G
which looks at four variables and
computes this and now here is a list of
polynomials which I say our projections
of G because I can obtain them by simply
instantiating each of the variables in G
by either one of these variables or by a
field constant so I just do a
substitution and this polynomial pops
out then I will say that this is a
projection of G here are examples which
are not projections for instance there
is no way I can get the polynomial y 1
square by 2 out of any substitution here
because substitution is not going to
increase the degree there's no way I can
get this polynomial out of G because
substitution cannot increase the number
of monomials so so projection is just
talking about substitution so you're
restricting your substitutions to either
variables or constants you're allowing a
friendly so far now I've restricted it
two variables or constants but later we
will also talk about a fine forms it's
not a major distinction so right now by
restricting it in this way I can say
this thing here that I F is a projection
of G if a circuit foji can be used to
compute F without using any extra gates
no extra operations of addition and
multiplication you may have lots of
buyers which re-route the variables of
the polynomial you are interested in
into the inputs of G but you don't have
to do any more computation so that's the
projection and I may also i will also
need to talk about poly SCI projections
as opposed to projections this is
important because we are talking not
about individual polynomials fng but
about families of polynomials so if I
want to say that this entire family f is
a projection of the family G will then
it's polynomial here i can write as a
projection of some ms polynomial in the
new family that m should not be too
large compared to n so i don't have to
go too far away in the target family so
that would be a polynomial projection so
this is a pictorial representation
circuit for G which has its own inputs
and I put it into a box in which there
are a few additional wires and field
constants but nothing more and the wires
group the variables of F and I end up
computing is so this is this is a engine
this is a P projection and if this M is
polynomial in n then it's also in
general that's the projection if M is
polynomial in n it's a P prediction so
with this notion of reductions talking
about when one polynomial family is
easier or harder than the other we know
that the Hamilton cycle polynomial is in
fact complete for v NP and Hamilton
cycle polynomial was an example of what
I call it a numerator polynomial the
monomials of the polynomial explicitly
list out all the Hamilton cycles in a
complete graph and now because in the
complete graph we have introduced a new
variable for every edge by instantiating
these variables we can pull out the
Hamilton cycles in any graph that we
want so what other enumerator polynomial
czar there that are hard like this will
there's a whole series of them in
particular here's one example
eliminating all the cliques again you
start with a complete graph and for
every subset of vertices you multiply
the variables corresponding to edges in
that little induced sub graph so there's
a monomial corresponding to a click for
every click there is such a monomial
remember the variables are sitting on
the edges of the graph not on the
vertices so so here's another way of
writing the cliq polar polynomial each
monomial can be described not by a set
of vertices but instead by a set of
edges you can look at a subset of edges
but that that edge set must satisfy this
property that it describes a click and
then maybe some isolated vertices and
then we multiply this so this
formulation is what's going to be
important to me later on so that's why I
put it up here so this polynomial is
also complete for VN p with respect to P
projections another example of an
enumerator polynomial is enumerated
perfect matchings and bipartite graphs
so just start with the complete
bipartite graph KNN and for every
perfect matching you have a
corresponding monomial and you add them
up and this is in fact exactly the
permanent so as even in this algebraic
complexity setting it is hard for v NP
but dis hardness as we know is only when
the characteristic is not too ok so we
have some examples of polynomial
families which are hard in algebraic
competition setting now here's another
polynomial which looks very much like
the preceding polynomials it I remember
it's cuts in a graph in the cotton
later Parliament so start with the
complete graph look at every partition
of the vertex set into two pieces a and
B and then multiply out the variables on
edges which go across the a be cut so
for every cut I have a monomial and
there are no other mono means so as an
example if if I'm looking at the third
polynomial so I have the graph k3 in
that the partition must have either it
either is a trivial partition zero and
one side and all three on the other
that's going to give rise to this
monomial or it has a partition where one
side has a singleton on the other side
has two elements so this monomial comes
out when vertex one is on one side and
two and three are on the other side and
similarly for the other two cases so
this is the cut polynomial for k3 now
you have a cut problem in 4k 4k 5 and so
on so this looks very much like the
other polynomials that we saw before
this that it's just eliminating these
combinatorial objects and it's not very
hard to see that it is in v NP so I
started off saying that this is a
remarkable a numerator polynomial so
what's so remarkable about it what is
remarkable about it is this result which
was shown by Peter Baker said 16 years
ago over the female GF to this
polynomial is neither in VN p not v NP
hard with respect to P projections
unless the pH collapses to the second
level so it's a conditional result but
and it's only over the field GF 2 but
it's still very interesting because the
previous polynomials that we listed out
were complete for v NP over every field
when not all the pollen permanent was
not complete over the characteristic too
so now here if the permanent was not
complete but this thing is saying
something more it's saying that it is
not in vp either whereas the permanent
we knew was in vp so this this
polynomial is an intermediate polynomial
unless languages which are in more to
pee-pee teepee have polynomial size
circuits that would also imply that the
pH collapses to the second level so this
is something unusual about this
polynomial and so let me briefly say a
few words about intermediate complexity
in the boolean world we know that there
are intermediate problems Ladner's
theorem from many many years ago tells
us that if P and NP are distinct then we
can find a language which is in between
PA
be complete and an exact analog of this
is also known on the algebraic word
bristle himself prove this in 1999 that
over every field it does not matter
which field you're looking at if V P and
V NPR distinct then there is a
polynomial which is in between which is
in which is it is definable but it's not
hard for definable polynomials and it is
not computable but the problem with
these two statements and their process
is that basically the proof demonstrates
the existence of such a language or such
a polynomial the existence is
demonstrated using diagonalization so
typically that the problem which is
intermediate is not very explicit very
not very nicely defined whereas the cut'
polynomial was so explicit so we don't
really have many examples of explicit
languages or polynomials that we know
are intermediate even in the boolean
world the language functions that comes
out of Ladner's construction is sacked
with some holes punched in so there is a
kind of natural looking definition but
where do you punch those holes that's
not easy to describe whereas the cut'
polynomial is very easily described so
in order to get this explicit
representation we need to assume a
little bit more so this the fact that
this cut polynomial is intermediate does
not just follow from the assumption that
define ability and compatibility are
different we also need an additional
assumption that parity p is hard for
poly size circuits which would also
imply that define ability and
compatibility are different so with an
additional assumption we can come up
with these explicit polynomials which
are provably intermediate and this was a
result only over GF 2 it's a very
natural question to ask whether such a
result also holds over other fields it
turns out that that cut polynomial
itself is in fact be np-complete over
reals so the arguments used to show that
it is intermediate we're very very
specific to this field over reals Nicola
Gregory alter showed this a few years
ago
you could also look at other fields so
other finite fields bit of abuse has
completely answered this question using
the cut polynomial itself fix any field
finite field of size Q and then you just
tinker with the cut polynomial by
raising every variable there to the
power Q minus one so from Fermat's
little theorem we know all this does is
to take zeros to zeros and non zeros to
one and then you can use the dimension
that worked over GF 2 so so what book is
so short was this over for every prime
power cube over the field FQ this
polynomial which I've listed out here
it's certainly in vnp and if counting
modulo P is easy then it is intermediate
so sorry unless it is easy this is it
I'm sorry yeah so it's counting modulo P
is something that we don't know how to
do efficiently even in a non-uniform
setting then we can prove that this cut
polynomial is neither hard for define
ability nor polynomial computable so
this was what Berg is a short in 1999
and since then these were the only known
intermediate complexity polynomials so
what we do is to come up with some new
intermediate polynomials and so one way
to see well because because the
definition of at least some of our
intermediate polynomials looks a bit
weird so maybe we should try and examine
where did that intermediate pneus of
those polynomial is coming from so so
the hamilton cycle polynomial or the
cliq polynomial they were not
intermediate they were hard and they
were hard because they're monomials
encoded the weights of some hard to find
community real object now this itself is
not a very satisfactory explanation
because cuts are also not very easy to
find if you're looking at large size
cuts but basically it says that there's
something to do with this encoding which
we have to carefully doctor so what we
do is that we put more information into
the encoding each monomial does not just
talk about maybe a click exactly a click
but it has some auxiliary information
also and that auxiliary information is
thrown in to make sure that the
resulting polynomial is not hard but
then you have to be careful if you throw
on too much information it may become
too easy so we just have to make sure
that we put in the right amount of
information so it comes down from be NP
hardness but stays
VP so the starting point is always be
np-hardness we're not starting from VP
and going up but starting from VN p.m.
coming down and the question is how to
put in this extra information using this
approach may come up with intermediate
polynomials which are based on encoding
these combinatorial objects click clicks
themselves but encoded in a different
way vertex covers closed walks
three-dimensional matchings as well as
three satisfiability so I'm going to run
you through the definitions of all these
polynomials and then just sketch very
briefly the intermediates proof for one
or two of them and in particular the
definition of click let me go over it a
little more in detail because there is
an old definition of click which we know
is hard and now here's a new definition
of a click polynomial which is not hard
so in the old definition I'm using this
formulation look at every subset of
edges if that subset of edges forms a
click and an isolated vertex then throw
in the monomial corresponding to it in
my new definition which thus
nomenclature terms of micro theory says
it works equally well for click or
independent sets so C is you take every
subset of the edges and don't enforce
this condition whatever the subset you
throw in the corresponding monomial but
now you throw an auxiliary information
into the same monomial so now we have
some new variables these are variables
which sit on the vertices of the graph
not on the edges so I throw in all the
edge variables from this set and then I
also multiply this monomial by the
vertex variables corresponding to those
vertices which are touched by this set
now if you look at this composite
monomial I mean of course it has it has
the information you need to check
whether this forms a click or no but in
particular the degree in the Y variables
is an indicator of whether or not this
is actually a click if you are touching
k vertices so that you have kate by
variables here then you would expect to
have K choose to X variables on the
other side so so so we just remove an
explicit condition from the subset but
then throw an auxiliary information oxa
using auxiliary variables which gives
you back that information now notice
that in this process we have thrown in a
whole lot of garbage into the polynomial
so we would have been interested only in
clay
but now here we have a lot of non clicks
also so the clicks are still there but
then there are non clicks so as an
example in the three vertex graph T
could have been the empty set it
contributes monomial one in both the
cases p could have been the click on
size of size 2 in which case in the old
definition it would have just given the
monomial x 12 now i get x 12 y 1 x 2 it
could also have been the entire edge set
in which case in the old polynomial i
would have gotten these three X
variables and in the new polynomial i
get 3x variables as well as the 3 by
variables but here are the kind of
garbage monomials so i have an edge set
with two edges it would not have
qualified in the old definition at all
but in the new definition this also want
abuse a monomial with those two edges
but the two edges touch all three
vertices so I have all three by
variables so our own an extra monomials
and idea is that by throwing in these
extra mana meals you can use then
somehow in the computation to make the
overall competition easier the idea of
throwing in stuff which eventually
they're cancels out or is irrelevant or
whatever so that's going to make this
new polynomial easier than the hard
polynomial at the same time it still has
information about a click so it cannot
become too easy that's that's the idea
so this is our definition of the cliq
polynomial and this is for GF 2 for
other fields exactly the same thing but
you just raise this to the power 2 minus
1 if you have a finite field of size K
minus 1 to come up
no so this is not a click precisely so
this is the garbage term yeah so sorry
in the original definition we only
wanted edges which form the click in the
new definition we are willing to handle
any subset of edges whether or not it
forms a click so this is something which
would not have appeared here at all and
here it appears with this Y information
so as I said over other fields we can
again use the same trick so in fact in
the subsequent slides I won't even
describe the other fields version let's
just work / GF 2 what about the sack
polynomial so we look at 3 set 3
satisfying satisfied duty of three see
any formulas so fix n we are looking at
formulas over n variables so there are
the n variables corresponding to those
variables in the formula itself and we
also introduced a 10 cube new variables
which correspond to potential clauses so
variable one of these variables denotes
whether that clause is actually present
in your input instance and now so if I
were given an actual formula I would
want somehow a sum over all satisfying
assignments of that formula so instead
hear what I do is I just look at all
assignments pull out the variables which
are one in that assignment and pull out
the clauses which that assignment
satisfies so these are just potential
clauses because I don't even have an
input formula just list out all the
clauses which this assignment can
satisfy so now when we instantiate y
with a specific formula of the clauses
which are present or no then this part
will kill assignments which are not
satisfying so again it has for any
specific formula that we will be
interested in this polynomial will have
information about the satisfying
assignments of that formula but because
we have thrown in in some sense garbage
it's going to become easier to compute
the closed walk polynomial so for this
maybe I should the brief a describe what
do I mean by a clover closed walk is
it's basically a path in the graph but
not necessarily a simple path you are
allowed to self intersect visit vertices
more than once even use edges more than
once but we are going to impose one
condition which is that the smallest
vertex in the path should not be visited
more than once the other vertices you
can there are no restrictions
the smallest vertex should not be
visited more than once other vertices
there is no restriction so this is what
we call a clue and based on clothes now
we have this polynomial which says look
at every clue every closed walk in the
complete graph a closed walk of length
exactly n my length I mean it has
exactly n edges it may touch fewer than
n vertices or all n vertices if it
touches all n vertices it would be a
Hamilton cycle but in general it could
be something else for that claw you look
at all the edges which I used in it
multiply out those variables now this
part in fact need not even be multi
linear because you could be using the
same edge more than once so you produce
some monomial here which may not even be
multi linear and then you throw in this
indicator part we have the new vertex
variables and you throw in every vertex
variable for you throw an inverted the
vertex variable for every vertex which
is touched by that clue so now again you
can see where Hamilton cycles sit in
this so a clue which is actually a
Hamilton cycle will give all NY
variables out here and it will give
something multi-linear out here and
direct
so all the hamilton cycles are sitting
in there but then a lot of non hamilton
cycles are also sitting in with
appropriate indicators so the presence
of the non hamilton cycles makes the
polynomial easy easier than be np-hard
and the presence of hamilton cycles
makes it hard so it is not in BP okay i
had this example i should so here's an
example of a clue of length 5 or 6 1 2 2
2 2 3 3 2 2 2 2 3 3 2 1 and that's going
to give rise to a monomial which has
degree 5 in the X variables X 1 2 is
used once 23 is used twice so i have x 2
3 square x 32 is used once and x 31 is
used once but then i have the by
variables and the y variables are not
thrown in with repetition so even though
a vertex may be visited more than once
it's very important for a proof later
that the by variables only one copy of
each at most one copy of each variable
is thrown in similarly I could have a
clue which looks even more simple from
one you go to two and you just keep
looping around there and then come back
that gives rise to amano me like this so
these are all garbage mama mia's which
turn out to be extremely useful later on
we have a similar definition for vertex
cover by now it's looking very similar
so maybe I should just skip this a set
of vertices they indicate are set for
that set and then further for the vertex
set and then the edges which are touched
by that we have a similar polynomial for
three dimensional matching you look at
three dimensional matches ins in a in a
complete tripartite graph and so instead
of looking at matching Z I'm just
looking at any subset of the hyper edges
and putting in the corresponding
monomials ok so so I listed out five new
polynomial families and I am kami that
all five of these are intermediate why
exactly are the intermediate so very
roughly I have already said it's because
of the garbage monomials make it easy
and the hard monomials make it hard but
how do you formally go around proving
this will be used exactly but business
strategy it just needed a little bit of
adaptation because that encoding was
different so what we need to show is
that for each of these polynomials cut
is what built a set himself shown and
the others we should for each of these
polynomials we need to show that it's in
v NP of course otherwise
we have nothing to go by now this part
is easy in all these cases so i won't
even talk about it we also need to show
that this these polynomials are easy and
the definition of easy which is
sufficient here is that over GF 2 they
can be evaluated in boolean p okay i
have a polynomial time algorithm which
given the values to all the variables in
the polynomial spits out the output
values not not in an algebraic
competition model by a ordinary turing
machine so in that sense this polynomial
is easy and if it is in if it is easy in
this sense but it cannot be hard in the
algebraic sense so if it once we show
that it is easy then a v NP hardness
would imply that parity p your mod 2p
also has small circuits and that would
contradict the assumption that we are
starting off with when we want to show
that something is intermediate for the
last part we need to show hardness we
need to show that this polynomial is
somehow hard to compute and therefore
it's not going to be in vp if it is in
DP then the same bad consequence should
happen in order to show this we want to
use the fact that the monomials of H are
encoding solutions of a crappy hard
problem so that's where the counting
comes in again it's the underlying
problem is sharply hard via parsimonious
reductions so if you look at these two
steps they kind of seem to be completely
in opposition to each other on the one
hand we are saying that H is easy to
evaluate its in p on the other hand
racing it's not on VP and this is in
fact the whole point about a difference
between the algebraic computation model
and normal computation that
algebraically if you want to
symbolically carry forward the entire
polynomial we don't know how to do it
and we don't expect to be able to do it
but on the other hand if you just want
to evaluate it at specific points then
that is easy so let me show by sat is
intermediate following that template as
i said the membership part i will not
show the membership in v NP is driven
why is this polynomial easy so I said we
need to show that or given specific
values to the variables i can evaluate
this in boolean p if a 0 1 assignment is
given to all the variables then notice
that i want to sum over all assignments
and each assignment is going to
contribute either a 0 or a 1 to the Sun
so when
contribute one for an assignment to
contribute of one it must be the case
that whenever an X variable takes the
value zero a should also be zero there
because otherwise the monomial gets
killed similarly whenever a clause takes
the value zero it must be the case that
assignment does not even satisfy this
close so the moment we are given values
to x and y some bits of a are completely
fixed in order that in order that a is
able to contribute to the some some bits
of a have to be fixed in a certain way
and the remaining bits of AR unfixed you
can change them in any way so therefore
the total son is exactly 2 raised to the
number of unconstrained boots so this
tells us that this is easy right in fact
because we are doing computation modulo
2 you just want to know whether there
are any and constraint bits still left
if you are looking at another field then
you will look at this some tourists to
the number of bits modulo P why is this
hard well the to see that it is hard we
start off with this polynomial and pull
out a bivariate polynomial out of it
given any real instance of three CNF SAT
so we are given an instance f which has
n variables and M clauses I'm going to
transform this formula by setting all
the Y variables to p.t is a new variable
and I am going to set a sorry not all
the variables all all the Y variables
corresponding the clauses which are
present I said to t the other variables
I said to one so they play no role and
the excess play no role in any case so I
get this not bivariate but univariate
polynomial t in in t and every
assignment a contributes a term p raise
to the number of clauses which are
actually satisfied by it and since we
are interested in satisfying assignments
we want this exponent here to be their
degree so we're just looking at the
coefficient of T to the N so so it's not
the value of this polynomial gives us
what we want but a particular
coefficient gives us what we want if
this polynomial very easily computable
then we would be able to do Co efficient
extraction also so this is the spirit in
which we can show that all those five
polynomials are intermediate and I do
have slides for two more of these but I
think
skip them why so the typical template is
to show why it is easy by saying that
the easy part boils down to something
completely trivial and the hard part is
to show where the monomials are encoding
these hard objects in in the case of
click it was a bivariate polynomial in
the case of SAT it was univariate in the
case of clothes it was again bivariate
and so on so let me stop with that topic
for now sorry I should go back yeah so
you said for this problem for the coast
works unique why Y variables to be
talking only once okay so so so for that
maybe I should look at the hardness part
I want to say that this polynomial
actually encodes Hamilton cycles and for
it to encode Hamilton cycles I'm going
to convert this polynomial to a
bivariate polynomial and in that
bivariate polynomial the coefficient of
Z to the N T to the N is going to be the
number of Hamilton cycles now if I throw
in my variables with multiplicity I may
get deep our end without having a
Hamilton cycle so it's important there
ok so actually I have results of three
different flavors which I want to
present and the first one was about
intermediate complexity let me now jump
to the next one which is animating graph
homomorphisms and here we have something
which is very different from
intermediate complexity so homomorphisms
we have seen a lot in this workshop so
we know what they are and the typical
questions or is there a more fizzled out
how many approximate how many and we are
going to ask again the question of
symbolically enumerate all the
homomorphisms so the so called a
numerator polynomial that we construct
for this looks something given two
graphs G and H I have variables sitting
on the edges of H so I'm thinking of G
is fixed and you know that that's why in
the abstract I said this is
homomorphisms from the left H has
variable sitting on every edge and as i
instantiate these variables i get
different target graphs H so now look
let's look at a polynomial corresponding
to homomorphisms from g2h for each
homomorphism free I just look at the
image of every edge and take the
corresponding edge variable multiply
them out into a monomial
so this is very similar in spirit to the
previous polynomials that we saw but of
course the underlying object here is not
hard so we don't expect this to be v NP
hard or v NP intermediate the question
is now how easy is it and what we show
is that it is it exactly characterizes
VP so this is our definition of the
polynomial again we need families so we
need families of graphs to describe
families of polynomials and the families
of graph should again grow reasonably
the N it graph should have number of
vertices which is polynomial in n okay
an example here look at a home off ism
like this it gives rise to a monomial
like this I think we've seen examples
also maybe the second skip the monomials
are just encoding the homomorphisms now
there's one notion that we use in our
inner result which is that of rigid and
incomparable graphs so a graph is rigid
if it has no nontrivial homomorphism to
itself most graphs are rigid a pair of
graphs is incomparable if there is no
homomorphism from A to B or from B to a
most phase of graphs are incomparable
and we will use these in a gadget
construction so here's the graph family
I'm going to describe now a graph family
after describe GN and a chin and then we
just look at homo morphisms from g2h so
the NF graph G I start with a complete
binary grass with exactly n leaves of
course n may not be a power of 2 so take
the pick the smallest next power of to
start off with a binary tree with
exactly not that power of two lanes and
we are fixing three graphs which are
known to be rigid and pairwise
incomparable and we plug in those graphs
into the street so at the root i plug in
the graph I zero and then at subsequent
alternate levels I 1 I 2 I 1 I 2 and so
on each of these graphs has some
designated attachment points so I use
those attachment points to connect the
gadgets to the next level or to the
parent and then I also have this bound
on the size of the whatever graphs I fix
the thighs total size to get better see
so I go back to the original edges of
the tree and I stretch them so that they
are all longer than C so this is my
family GN complete binary tree each node
inflated into one of those gadgets
and each original tree is stretched into
a long path and the family H is is the
complete graph on an appropriate number
of vertices what we show is that
homomorphisms from g2h in this family is
exactly complete for VP for polynomial
time computability of Palma means and
this completeness is with respect to P
projections in fact there's a slight
modification of that where instead of
the graph being a binary tree if I start
with a simple path then I get
completeness for a slightly smaller
class presumably smaller class which is
a polynomial is computed by branching
programs but I think I won't talk about
of the homomorphism polynomial yeah so
it's the number of edges in G so to the
logger yes
because every age is contributing one
variable out there okay so and we
started off with a different kind of
animator and we got VP completeness and
it's a fairly natural question to us
what's the big deal about this well to
us for the big deal was that this is the
first natural complete polynomial for VP
so as a computation model you know
polynomial size polynomial degree
circuits it's extremely natural but
there were no natural polynomial is
known for this class so there were some
generic polynomials known that you the
circuit classes base is defined based on
circuits so you take a canonical circuit
computation and pull out a family out of
it of course that would be complete but
for most reasonable complexity classes
you expect that problems arising from
various domains turn out to be complete
for them and there was really nothing
known to be complete for VP with respect
to polynomial projections if you allow
slightly larger projections quasi
polynomial size projections when has
been known for a long time we ensured it
i think in 79 that the determinant is
complete for vp but it does require this
quasi polynomial bro blow we don't know
whether it can be done with a polynomial
blow up so the big deal for us was that
this is so there is this caveat this is
almost the first two years ago with
another bunch of authors we had also
shown that sample some polynomials based
on graph homomorphisms were VP complete
but there never many things which were
not satisfactory in particular either
the VP completeness was with respect to
Oracle deductions not projections or the
homo morphisms came with caveats you
know you look at only injective
homomorphism look at only directed
homomorphisms and so on so so there were
various such caveats and in this result
there's nothing I mean there are
families are cleanly described and we
are looking at all homomorphisms for
algebraic branching programs complete
polynomials were known earlier
determinant my i triggered matrix
multiplication so here's one more from
the homomorphism framework and one point
and notice that our upper bounds
actually the computing the homomorphism
polynomial from g2h they hold whenever G
has bounded three width NH is complete
so in our example G was bounded trivet
because we started with a tree and then
we put in these gadgets and the upper
bound holds whenever it's bounded tree
with
okay so this is the this is the second
flavor of the results and in the next
last 5-6 minutes let me try and describe
the third flavor of results which is a
completeness with respect to monotone p
projections so P projections were
already restrictive enough and what can
get more restrictive well there was this
do-nothing reduction talked about but
here that's not what I'm talking about
I'm talking about looking at P
projections they're still you have wires
going all over the place but you are not
allowed to use negative constants so
this makes sense of course only if you
are talking over a totally ordered semi
ring so to compute F from Ju take a
circuit from G and replace each variable
of G by either a variable of F or by a
constant if you replace it by a constant
that constant must be greater than 0
okay so so we can talk about when f is a
monotone projection of G now the this
makes sense all the columns that I
listed out earlier were monotone they
had 0 1 coefficients so the polynomial
the descriptions of the pollen owners
themselves were monotone why would one
want to relate them by a monotone
projections well one bowl would be to
get lower bounds for restricted circuits
in particular for more dirt on circuits
so jacana observed this a couple of
years ago that if somehow we can show
that the Hamilton polynomial which
itself is monotone is a monotone p
projection of the permanent ok before
before I read further let me just point
out that the Hamilton cycle is
definitely a P projection of the
permanent because the permanent is v NP
hard but the point is that that
projection is not known to be monotone
so we are emphasizing monotone and poly
sighs now if the Hamilton cycle is a
monotone poly sighs projection of the
permanent then we can show a monotone
circuit lower bound for the permanent
which is exponential and this will
improve the best-known bound over for
boolean circuits so for boolean circuits
as far as I know the best bound is what
rosborough showed an 85 quasi polynomial
size is required by monitoring circuits
over reals we know better so over reals
if the statement were true that Hamilton
is a monotone p position of the
permanent then it will give a
and proof of this non-reserved due to
German snare also from many years ago
number of my chains is it still no I
don't know I don't know so somehow we
have been thinking only about permanent
and only after coming here I've been
seeing that you know looking at perfect
matchings in general would also be an
interesting much more interesting thing
to look at where that so I don't know I
don't so this is why one would even want
to ask this question are there monotone
poly size projections what Groucho
showed in response to this comment from
jigna is that any monotone projection
from permanent down to Hamilton must
have an exponential blow so if you want
to write the Hamilton cycle polynomial
as a monotone projection of the
permanent of a perhaps larger matrix
then that perhaps larger will have to be
significantly larger that's really what
this is so so so do pros idea was that
well we know that the clique is a
monotone p projection of the Hamilton
that's that's known and therefore if you
can show this with poly blow up then a
lower bound from click transfers to a
lower bound from permanent so what we
show is that this kind of thing you know
monotone projection we can also show it
for some other families in particular
for two of our intermediate families SAT
and chlo we show that they are certainly
not monotone poly size projections of
the permanent now this is exactly the
same in spirit to this result by Groucho
these are not conditional results
they're just saying that monitor the
city is a real restriction and you
cannot do this in fact so specifically
if you project down from the permanent
to get fat using only non negative
constants than the blow-up they'll have
to be to raise to square root in if you
project down to close and the blow-up
will have to be to to the Omega N and
more recently written in fact sure that
even to come down to the cliq itself you
would need to to the square root n so
this completely kills the the hope of
transferring a lower bound from click to
permanent via this approach why a
monotone p projections so in fact this
was the question where jonah had raised
earlier but he somehow couched it in
terms of the hamilton cycle and we can
show this directly for the cliq how do
we prove this kind of results the
prove that any any monotone project so
here somebody asked earlier about a fine
versus variable so here the statement
goes through even for a fine projections
provided in the fine combinations you
don't use negative constants so okay so
how do they show this basically we're
using groucho's idea and then we pick up
various results which are known in the
literature so we are going to associate
polytopes with the polynomials as well
as with the solution sets in particular
for the permanent the polytope which we
look at is the convex hull of all
bipartite perfect matchings so look at
the complete graph ktt it has t square
edges so let's look at dimension t
square or t or t square dimensional
vector and look at the zero one
indicator variable of a perfect matching
it will have exactly T ones and the
remaining zeros so look at all such
vectors take their convex hull that's
that's a polytope yes yes I was trying
to not use that word okay yeah and this
polytope can be described with or dirty
inequalities for satisfiability also
this is also the Newton polytope which
is you look at the vectors of degrees of
monomials in the polynomial and then you
take their convex combination so for the
satisfiability polynomial that we looked
at we have this polytope in n plus 18
cube dimensions but actually the first n
bits completely dictate what happens in
the remaining eight and cube positions
now avisynth Avari have shown that there
are formulas for which even so you want
to look at the combinations of
satisfying assignments that that's the
polytope that you're really interested
in for these formulas even if you take
this polytope and look at its embedding
in a higher dimension to describe that
polytope you would require lots of
inequalities so the extension complexity
of the satisfying assignment polytope
for some formulas is huge so now you put
these two together and then there is
this step which gocho sure if you have a
monotone pay projection from F to G then
the extension complexity of F is bounded
by the size of the projection and the
description complexity of G so that
tells us that the satisfiability
polynomial if it has to be written as
the permanent the blow-up must be huge
because otherwise you would have a small
scription of these formulas which are
sitting here for the closed sequence
polynomial is the TSP polytope the
traveling salesperson polar polytope
which is sitting inside the Newton
polytope of clothes the traveling
salesperson polytope we know has large
extension complexity rato showed this a
couple of years ago and therefore it
follows that you cannot go get the cloak
all polynomial from the permanent
polynomial using monotone projections
and okay i mentioned that nathan also
showed this for click there he needed to
use the correlation polytope which also
has this little box ok so to summarize
as I mentioned there were results of
three different flavors we showed that
some polymers are intermediate under
complexity theoretical some shins we
showed that two of these families cannot
be expressed as monotone policies
projections of the permanent the blow-up
is probably large and then we came up
with a numerator polynomial based on
homomorphisms which are actually VP
complete and is the first natural family
that we know of which is complete for VP
so that message is that with
homomorphisms actually there's a lot
more that one could do because there are
also be np-complete variants and so on
and open questions well there are many
so intermediate complexity can we
address this question over all fields
right now we only do it for finite
fields and somehow depending on the
field size you have a different
polynomial can we come up with one
polynomial which works on all fields of
the same characteristic we don't even
know that the second question is related
to intermediate complexity polynomials
which you can write nicely through the
as a permanent and so so so these are
some questions that we are still looking
at thank you
so do you know the symmetry group of
this natural intermediate but the
natural plateau meal for DP no the graph
homomorphism pokémon I don't know
you know for pending before the novel of
accounting with the extra variables
which allow you to throw some garbage
like non clicks but which it shows up in
the in the usual County problem where
instead of counting proper objects you
saying okay allow some violations and
then usually in terms of just computing
the hardness doesn't change whether but
somehow here that so that suggested the
way that VPN is even harder than number
D or it's that ok so the separating
begin p from vp is necessary to separate
me from NP but to separate me from
Sharpie also yes i would think my
impression is that ok so i dont melis
V&T harder than shy i didn't think of it
that way to be exists that in the
algebraic computation model it's easier
to show lower bounds because you have
really tied your hands together by
saying that you can't zero in on to
individual mounam you have to
symbolically carry forward the whole
competition so it should be easier to
show that some things cannot be done but
but the usual County problem you some
extra variables allow the notation
usually w make the problem easier it
does not make it easy the penalty so
that that then it's you can a problem
you can't do there there are certain
things like that but usually just as as
bad as the original problem how here
it's not as bad okay I don't have a
better answer
can you produce infinitely many examples
I mean I'm sure we can instead of
counting over creeks in the normally if
you can do the same thing in Europe so
we did briefly try coming up with a meta
theorem like this but i think i would
also need to specify what is the
encoding that i use so what is the extra
garbage that I throw and then somehow I
don't know how that can be made
independent of the comm unit or X of the
specific problem that we are looking at
i don't know as yet so therefore edges
and vertices to exchange is below yeah
so it's not care that there's always
going to be enough to show intermediate
pneus to prove this as a theorem that
once you do this you have yeah i don't
know how to do that yet